i think dumplings are amazing because
everyone loves it if you say dumpling
everyone's faces will light up hi i'm
daniel and i'm making monday today manda
is a korean style dumpling it's similar
it's the korean version of what a lot of
americans know as pot stickers you know
i'm not entirely sure why they do use
tofu i actually didn't realize that most
other cultures don't use tofu as for why
you have to extract the water if you
don't it will make the mandu too watery
i have the basic recipe for my mom my
mom actually eyeballs most of the spices
and whatnot so i had to get more exact
specifications online it's pretty rare
to make monday these days unless it's
for korean new year's and even then me
and my mom haven't made it in a while or
after finding out that i made it for
this video she actually wants to restart
the tradition of making it for new
year's again
true story
i use egg and water because it helps the
skin stick better for some reason when i
just use water it never seems to stick i
don't know what everyone else's secret
is it just doesn't work for me
growing up korean american especially
because i'm only half was definitely a
little bit confusing
but one of the easiest ways to connect
with korean culture and with my mom was
always through food
making mandu is one of the more fun ways
to connect with my korean heritage food
in general has always been one of the
easiest ways for me and my mom to
connect which was very important for her
and ultimately very important for me to
help me understand my heritage and where
my mom came from
hi my name is lisa and today i'm going
to be making gote gote are chinese
dumplings otherwise known as pot
stickers we're using napa cabbage we
sprinkle salt on top of it to help draw
some of the water out because we don't
want too much moisture in the dumplings
because then it will be soggy and it
will fall apart
i don't remember
exactly the first time we had gote at
home i just always remember whenever
there was chinese new year or a special
occasion my mom would make the dumplings
i just always remember them being an
exciting part because whenever there was
something fun happening there would be
dumplings so i would know that it would
be an exciting time
when i was a kid some of my favorite
times were getting to spend time with my
mom in the kitchen and we didn't have a
lot of money when we were growing up but
we always had enough food no matter how
little money we had and i had a lot of
allergies growing up as well and i would
remember that my mom would make me
special food so to me i will always
remember food is love and if i can help
cook and i can feed other people that's
a way that i can show other people love
hi i'm sanjana and today i'm making
nepali momo nepali momo is a kind of
steamed dumpling that's essentially
nepali street food so i'm not from nepal
i'm actually south indian but my best
friend nikita is nepali and this recipe
is actually her mom's so the thing that
really excites me about momo is that the
flavors in the filling are super
familiar to me i've grown up on indian
cooking my mom uses a lot of turmeric
and a lot of garam masala amongst other
spices in a lot of her cooking so when i
had momo that was packaged inside of
this really tiny type of dumpling it was
really fun to be able to have that much
flavor that was just bite-sized and
poppable it was just a little piece of
home inside this really tiny dumpling as
opposed to soy sauce nepali momo use a
chutney it just tastes so delicious with
the filling that's inside the momo momo
are definitely finger food so use your
hands pick up a momo dip it in the sauce
and enjoy them
hi i'm ryan i'm making japanese gyoza
dumpling today gyoza is japanese style
dumpling i got this recipe from my mom
and she eyeballs all the ingredients
which is a typical mom thinks to do
she uses a lot of neera chives i think
that it's the secret for her gyoza kyota
is one of the first days i learned how
to cook for my mom
the memory i have of making gyoza is how
fast my mom can fold them
i only make one and she already made
five
it's been a while since i made a gyoza
with my mom but i bet she still makes
them faster than me i usually pan fried
gyoza after you line the gyoza in a pan
you will add water to steam them i'm
adding a tablespoon of flour into the
water so it will create extra crispy
base we call this hane which translates
to wings this style of gyoza is really
popular in japan when i make gyoza i
usually end up making hundreds of them
it freezes grey it's great for meal prep
every culture has their own verge of
dumplings
cooking connects people and has a strong
attachment to memory
i hope after watching this it will bring
back all the fun memories you had with
your family or friends
or create new one with some dumplings oh
yes
you